what's going on everyone it is your
buddy josh and i am partnering with
draftkings the leader in daily fantasy
sports because we want you to win
millions of dollars i wish i had that
sound effect
and by the way my nipples get hard when
i say millions of dollars
that is because it's a lot of money and
you can win it and guess what i know
you're like i don't know that much about
football you don't need to my wife beats
me every week just by drafting people
[ __ ] things are handsome
but here's all you need to do is you
download the app you put in the promo
josh wolf all caps no space
and then you draft your team easy nine
players each player assigned to value
that value can't go over fifty thousand
dollars
you get points from touchdowns field
goals
you know how it goes
and you can win millions of dollars
every single week
of the regular season millions of
dollars wait a second
millions of dollars get in there
look man
for me the greatest privilege of my life
for sure
was raising my three kids without a
doubt man there's so much joy in it if
you don't sweat the small stuff and you
really think of this is this is what a
[ __ ]
great uh experience and opportunity to
watch these [ __ ] people grow up so
dope so [ __ ] dope right
but i will tell you something else three
happy parents i i will
everybody else like i don't know what
you're talking about it [ __ ] eats
dicks i don't like it at all
[Applause]
but i will tell you if you're a parent
you know you found yourself in
conversations that are just like how did
this happen
let me tell you the single most random
conversation i've ever had
happened at my dinner table so my oldest
son was already out of the house my
daughter caitlin was probably 15. jacob
was like 11 and a half 12. and my wife
was sitting across from me and my
daughter just starts to cry
she's like
hey guys i'm so embarrassed that i
haven't shared this with you but
i hear my parents and i love you and i
don't want you to be disappointed in me
but i love you so much
and she said i just want you to know
i'm dating amanda which is her best
friend i go okay and then jacob goes i'm
in an armenian gang i was like what
[Applause]
when i turn to my wife i'm like before i
go any further do you have anything
you'd like to admit
she was like no nothing that beats
either one of these i was like yeah
so i said to my daughter i go babe she
was no i'd like to hear about the gang
first i go yeah me too okay
[Applause]
i said hey man tell me what that means
you're in an armenian gang
and he goes well
and by the way jager wolf i don't know
why this dude has always stood like
forrest gump i have no idea
[Applause]
so he i go what does that mean a meeting
gang goes well
we sit at lunch together
and we make fun of the other armenians
and i go i go
not other armenians
you're not armenian
[Applause]
and i said do they know you're not
armenian he goes i i think so
i go so all you got to do is make fun of
the armenians together and he goes yeah
i go yeah you can be in that gang that's
fine
then i said to my daughter i want you to
know and you have to know this comes
from your mom and i
we don't care who you date
if that person is good to you you're
good to them you respect each other that
person makes you feel good about
yourself and loved
we don't care
who that person is and she said thank
you i said of course yeah but
i mean no more sleepovers you know what
i'm saying
you really [ __ ] that up for yourself
didn't you
[Applause]
you could have been 50 honest and
[ __ ] ah whatever you wanted tonight
but i guess you're
you're in the room with us aren't you
and jacob was like why no more
sleepovers i was like just be armenian
dummy you don't need another [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]